it's a constant refrain amongst Moniz  that spendthrift Greeks are costing  thrifty Germans a fortune who worked so  hard to earn their money but now study  by the iwh Research Institute in hollis  as Germany has actually done quite well  out of the crisis since 2010 Germany has  been able to save some 100 billion euros  in interest payment on its sovereign  bonds that's far more than the sum  greasers Germany directly or indirectly  that amounts to approximately 90 billion  euros Germany has profited mainly  because during the crisis global  investors bought german bonds as a safe  asset with demand so high berlin was  able to cut the interest it has to pay  on its bonds to attract investors the  halleh study says that every time Greece  came under the financial market  spotlight again in recent years German  bond rates fell again but while that is  good for the state private savers have  lost a potential fortune because they  also only get rock-bottom interest on  their deposits